[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur stanleys
welt hatte gibt es eine eistorte mit
fünf verschiedenen cremes hier unten
habe ich dann am martini boden darüber
ich glaube es war erst die bombe creme
dann erdbeere blaubeere vanille und die
hand des obergerichtes unten himbeer
dafür dass je nach dem ist egal wer bist
du ja schon morgen eingekauft joshua
wollen ich habe schon verarbeitet
eingefroren und jetzt können wir gleich
erst richtig zu möchte ich meine richtig
also auch ich glaube ich die doppel und
ich auch weil es okay murat ich nehme es
einfach mal jetzt als kompliment an die
torte ist wirklich genial weil man
wirklich nichts backen muss der ofen
kann ausbleiben und man braucht nur eine
gefriertruhe
die zubereitung ist auch sehr einfach
und sehr schnell aber man hat natürlich
die wartezeit und muss damit die
einzelnen schichten entstehen immer mal
wieder einfrieren lassen wieder was
auffüllen
aber zur zubereitung insgesamt waren
echt nur 20 minuten auf 6 stunden
verteilt ich habe das vor einem jahr
machen sondern eben genau was wird als
frau der ganztag natürlich gemacht und
ich hab gegrillt nebenher und anderes
video gedreht als war echt super hier
auf über hausfrauen so zu reden
morattis kommen spruch besucher selber
reinigen oder so auch die hatte murat
bringt nämlich was macht die wäsche und
zwar weg aber ich zeige euch jetzt erst
einmal die zutaten die ich dafür
benötige für den norden brauche ich 200
gramm am martini kekse 100 gramm butter
die habe ich bereits geschmolzen
50 g gehackte mandeln etwas tonkabohne
und elemente davon verwende ich aber nur
die schale ist nämlich zuerst mal die
amaryllis die sind so dunkeln weil es
schoko am martini sind damals neu
entdeckt auch mal ganz schön probieren
wir jetzt aus und die werden jetzt ganz
kurze kleinert entweder in einem
gefrierbeutel mit dem aufbaustab oder im
mixer
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich da direkt die flüssige
butter mit dazu kann ich nämlich alles
hier mixa verrühren dann die mandeln
tonkabohne da wird einfach mit kleine
prise ist mit dazu gegeben so lecker und
wir sind limetten abrieb da ist
natürlich wichtig dass die mieter nicht
behandelt wurde
jetzt nämlich einen bakri den habe ich
bereits eingestellt auf 18 zentimeter
durchmesser und jetzt mir einfach den
oberboden rhein weg war nicht gebacken
wird
und jetzt mit einem klaren schönen fest
drücken also optisch gefällt mir das
richtig gut mit dem shop ramazzotti
[Musik]
jetzt schlage ich mich gefragt ob hier
ein mann vermisst nicht wo man kommt die
torte ich schon mal ins theater und ich
zeigt auch irgendwie hart und ich leben
die creme verwende ich 400 gramm
schlagsahne 300 gramm joghurt mit zehn
prozent fettanteil 250 gramm maccarone
120 gramm puderzucker etwas war der
extrakt und limettensaft und jeweils 100
gramm warum werden erdbeeren und
himbeeren nehmen jetzt zuerst einmal die
sahne und die wird ganz steif geschlagen
[Applaus]
und weil es eine eistorte wird braucht
jetzt auch keinen salat
die sache ist jetzt stelle ich die
restliche krems berühren also nehme ich
da jetzt den joghurt und dann nämlich
den zehnprozentigen damit die torte
schön cremig wird ihr könnt auch in
dreieinhalb prozentigen nehmen aber da
ist ja mehr wasseranteil drin und dann
wird später ein bisschen erkenntnisse
wenn wasser gefriert damit sowie
kristalline und so wird bisschen
cremiger mascarpone dazu oder zucker
butter zucker etwas vanille extrakt und
limettensaft und limettensaft ist
oftmals ein bisschen besser als
zitronensaft weißmüller schmeckt nicht
ganz so sauer ist und ein ganz tolles
aroma hat aber ich liebe achtet jetzt
kurz verrühren und dann die sahne
unterheben
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier fünf sternchen und
zwar werde ich ja die brombeeren
erdbeeren blaubeeren himbeeren pürieren
zum glück keine eisbären und werde vier
teile also bunt machen und ein teil
bleibt weiß so dass er einfach fünf
verschiedene cremes habe jetzt nehme ich
hier erst mal 100 gramm weg denn die
beeren wegen jeweils 100 gramm und damit
jede schicht gleich gleichmäßig wird
muss natürlich die weiße schicht
bisschen mehr haben also 100 gramm schon
mal weg und jetzt werde ich die übrige
creme ab ich habe vor hat die
glasschüssel gerade darf man nicht
vergessen und dann einfach aufteilen auf
alle fünft- und wie gesagt die weiße
krähe hat 100 gramm insgesamt mehr
[Musik]
die bären führe ich jetzt einzeln
nacheinander in der schüssel und dann
wird das potpourri jeweils mit einem
weißen schälchen verrührt
[Musik]
so sehen die verschiedenen creme sitz
aus die weiße ist noch im kühlschrank
und jetzt möchte ich ja dass sich
einzelne schichten habt das heißt der
partys ein bisschen aufwendiger
ich will jetzt die erste schicht ein das
ist die bombe schicht die kommt hier
rein und dann muss ich die torte
einfrieren für etwa eine halbe stunde
bis die schicht fest ist dann kommt die
nächste schicht wieder einfrieren
die nächste und die anderen cremes
stelle ich so lange in den kühlschrank
damit den nicht schmelzen
[Musik]
ich glaube jetzt einfach ein bisschen
damit die schlicht schön glatt wird und
so kann sie jetzt gefroren werden
[Musik]
veranstaltungs intrigieren
es kann auch sein dass immer noch nicht
ganz gefahren war
du bist einfach heiß man es heißt die
demo auch murat ist gucken kinder zu
also hast auch wenn die heißen scharfen
messer arbeiten wo sind wir denn hier
gelandet
bitte sei gefroren bitte sei gefroren
ich habe selbst vier stunden
ich habe mich gerade verschlug es auch
wir müssen uns jetzt gehalten weil ich
habe einen kalten getränken meine rosen
jetzt ist nicht einfach von oben runter
die optik ist doch mal der hammer oder
mit den verschiedenen beeren richtig
schön gepflegt jan gorr zum spaß dies
mit joghurt auch wenn bis heute immer
gelogen habe bitter ist dieses hobby ist
echt genial so richtig ich weiß nicht
warum ich ihm das nicht glauben kann
aber ich glaube es schmeckt wirklich
grün sonst ja das jetzt einfach stehen
lassen
nee wirklich lecker wie hast du probleme
kriegen waren sie nur heute hast du
gekauft
falls er dieses rezept gerne nachmachen
wollt dann schaut aufs ellis - blog.de
vorbei probiert einfach mal aus ich
finde die torte allein von der optik her
schon richtig schön postet ein bild auf
instagram kalinke ich dabei markiert
mich und ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen kunden die einen guten
appetit und bis zum nächsten
der bonner sommer und sie tritt der
boden dieser maritim chocolat magazine
lesen richtig gut ich bin diesmal
starten ist richtig cool ja selber
probieren so als kleine pop sichtlich
werden sie bestimmt auch süß
[Musik]